I want to talk to you our listeners and
viewers about something Hillary Clinton
did and I want you to tell me whether I
should be angry about it Hillary Clinton
used a private jet for what is basically
a 20 to 40 mile trip okay depending on
the route taken by the airplane over the
weekend she was on the island of
martha's vineyard massachusetts with
president obama and she flew to the
smaller island of Nantucket
Massachusetts which depending on exactly
what route you take is about a 20 to 40
mile flight okay uh Drive uh well no
it's a flight and you can try me this
two islands you'd have to take a ferry
but it's about twenty to forty mile
flight um lots of the usual right-wing
media are making a big deal out of how
privileged Hillary Clinton is and
honestly I don't really care about that
I mean Donald Trump owns a 757 or 737 he
owns it Hillary is just flying on one so
this is not for me a story about
privilege at all jet airplane takeoffs
consume absurd amounts of fuel right if
you compare fuel consumption during
takeoff up versus fuel consumption
during cruise flight the take-off is
insanely wasteful in terms of fuel
consumption you're flying twenty to
forty miles it's all take off and you
might hear this and say David we'll
listen you know uh to get Hillary
Clinton on a ferry over to Nantucket and
then ferry back security concerns and
you have to drive to the ferry well I
don't know that's a good argument
because she'd still have to drive to and
from each Airport you would still have
to coordinate transportation yeah she'd
have to bury it back to Martha's
Vineyard before getting back on the
private jet to go to the next place but
when you're trying to make the argument
that you care about the climate when
you're trying to make it seem as though
you really are connected to the people a
20 to 40 mile private jet flight from
one island to another it strikes me as a
very bad political decision it's not a
critique of privilege both Trump and
Hillary are very rich Trump if you
believe him more so than Hillary this
makes no sense in terms of just the
climate impact does it it oh no no no um
but we know that Hillary the climates
and and and um the environment it that's
not
a priority of Hillary Clinton we know
that uh but this is just what you do
this is what you do in your honor
campaign this is what you do when you're
Hillary Clinton or uh Donald Trump and
this isn't surprising to me but it is
bad optics and and they should have
considered that uh of course I don't
like it but it's just business as usual
if you are going to write to me and tell
me that this is not something that I
should be critical of explain exactly
why and the the explanation that Hillary
is not as bad as Trump because he owns
the jet and Hillary Clinton rents the
jet and Hillary Clinton is a Democrat
and Trump is a Republican for me Jason
that's not a good explanation if I see
an action that I believe makes no sense
like a twenty-mile private jet flight in
the midst of what is a huge climate
disaster I get it the 120 mile flight
it's not gonna be the be-all end-all
it's not gonna solve the the climate
crisis it's not gonna also make it
drastically worse but this is just a
very bad decision isn't it and I think
kind of like loses point he missed a
huge opportunity here her on you know
the ferry go from when I want the other
with the people great optics but but I
can see you know she is for the people
in that you know they would have bumped
entire you know fairy maybe get a
private ferry but I know from you know
live in the cape and I've gaand islands
many times yeah trying to get on that
ferry there's usually like our law many
hour long lines okay that's not bad
Jason is finding a silver lining here
which is these fairies are annoying
enough to begin with if Hillary Clinton
is on a ferry you'd better believe that
if there's going to be late people
allowed on it a secret service is going
to be heavily involved in
inconveniencing all of those people or
they might make it so that there's a
ferry trip just for Hillary Clinton
would which would disrupt all ferry
traffic so I i I'm shocked that somehow
we found a silver lining to justify this
jason has done it that is that is
something it's true yeah well when
you're campaigning in you doing as many
stops she is you're all over the place
you pick the path of least resistance
yeah and I guess that's twenty mile
private jet flight send me your thoughts
on this am I missing something and this
this is something I should be okay with
I don't get it but I'm willing to hear
emails from